have your credentials out have your
credentials out so we verify
of the many twists and turns of the
trump presidency
another just as the american tv networks
were preparing to declare joe biden the
winner
the team representing the loser were in
an industrial estate in the philadelphia
suburbs
one two three test a news conference had
been called
why here we don't know but with the
podium in place
out walk the president's lawyer rudy
giuliani
wow what a beautiful day thank you with
him witnesses he said
to mass electoral fraud but they were
uniformly
uh deprived of their right to inspect
any single part of the mail-in ballot
it's three days since he first alleged
fraud since then he says he's found
50 witnesses but only a handful were
available to speak
you have provided three people you say
you've spoken
about 50 people you say you've no you
say you've interviewed 25 of those
i have statements from 25 we've spoken
to right that's 15. every single
inspector
that's 50 people in three days that that
the president's lawyer has been able to
find with presumably the houston speak
to them
are you the lawyer for the other side by
the way no you should get paid for it
i'm playing devil's advocacy
once again he said that republican
observers had been unable to monitor the
counts
despite us speaking to republican
observers
and as he spoke the news came in that
joe biden had been declared the victor
who was a call by all the networks oh my
goodness
all the networks wow
all the networks we have to forget about
the law
judges don't count
[Applause]
perhaps this is why they chose the
industrial estate they wouldn't be heard
or welcomed here in downtown
philadelphia
a city in a state which delivered donald
trump the white house four years ago
pennsylvania is now the state which
pushed joe biden over the line
but yards away a few of donald trump's
most loyal were holding firm
and playing his old speeches or maybe
even
sooner
back at the industrial estate the
president's lawyer left defiant
his client he says will take this all
the way to the supreme court
mark stone sky news in philadelphia